working with separate systems to analyze
structured and unstructured data give me
a minute and I can show you how to
seamlessly integrate unstructured data
analytics within bigquery using object
tables a new type of table in bigquery
that provides a structured record
interface for unstructured data stored
in Google Cloud Storage
by expanding big lake to enable
unstructured data analytics using
bigquery you can now process analyze
secure govern search and share
unstructured data using the familiar SQL
interface and without needing to learn
new tools this enables you to natively
run analytics and machine learning on
images audio documents and other file
types using existing processing
Frameworks such as bigquery ML and
remote user-defined functions
these tables provide pre-signed URLs for
the enlisted Uris that called the remote
udfs running on cloud functions or Cloud
run
since object tables contain metadata
such as URI content type and size they
can be queried just like other bigquery
tables allowing you to run machine
learning models for predictions on
unstructured data using bigquery ml you
can also employ remote udfs run through
Cloud functions or Cloud run that access
Google's pre-trained AI models these
include Vision AI speech API NLP API
translate API or deploying your own
custom models where performance slas are
important object tables also extend
Google data Cloud's best practices of
securing sharing and governing
structured data to unstructured without
needing to learn or deploy new tools for
example fine-grained access controls
like row level security are included and
act just like bigquery native tables
additionally analytics Hub is available
to share unstructured data with Partners
customers and suppliers while not
compromising on security and governance
this emphasizes the simplicity of
Google's data Cloud by enabling powerful
analysis on all types of data with a
simple SQL statement
bring analytics and machine learning to
your unstructured data thanks to
bigquery object tables contact a Google
sales specialist to use bigquery for
your unstructured data or check out the
documentation to learn more
[Music]